bring it to you I ain't killing it
struck my chin real slow when I'm lying
and I was laughing super hard and gone
that was dying the name of the album is
I killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and besides
enough
excuse me big man big man big man excuse
me big man no but big man okay God bless
you I'll catch you on the cup flip thank
you big man thank you big man hey
brother hey can I ask you a question
real quick though brother man oh see
that's good cause I was about to ask you
a question okay so here's the deal man
crazy thing my car went out okay it's
about a mile up the road this way I was
just wonder if I get a little bit of
money you know just get a couple of
gallons okay that's crazy because you
know what this my car had also broke
down right up the road yeah I got my
daughter here she's fine she's sleeping
in the car I gotta get back to her real
quick so if you could help me out I was
gonna ask you if you can help me okay
let me just give you my wallet out here
and show you my ID to let you know that
I am straight up the Jets real they
ain't trying to try to do nothing to
nobody okay uh issue of legitimacy I do
have an identification that's an
employee ID from Borders bookstore right
here I got my Bally's Total Fitness ID
right shows you that I stay fit and
conscientious and whatnot you'll also
notice of these other IDs I have in my
hand have the same name on it which
makes you know that it is indeed me okay
I got to have multiple IDs Crescendo
Wing in this
Yogurtland punch card okay yeah I've
seen that right there that is my ninth
purchase apparently and you can't wait
I'm still good for that yeah all right
so normally I would not ask another
person for an assistance but our our
family is in a fiduciary crisis right
now my wife is languishing in the
hospital to see a construction worker
and what happened is she got struck in
the face by a power line fried her whole
head up burnt both her eyeballs out
she's getting the eyeball replacement
surgery as we speak I also have a
spousal injury crisis on my midst as
well my wife was in the astronaut
program making her a full-fledged
astronaut okay and she had gotten Moon
dust in her lungs inhaled that's never
good no it's never good
to ATM
oh no oh looks one over there
what's the chances of it we should
probably check that out yeah let's just
take a look right there here we are well
here we are ATM machines that I did not
know previously were here all right two
of them no less I'll tell you what we
should do though man you give me the 20
okay I'll give you the three that's on
my person then I will give you the 17
after then you give me that 17. I'll cut
you a check for a hundred just to cover
that you give me the change in cash okay
okay I feel that why am I playing I'm
just gonna give you my ATM card so you
know I'm Legit
I'm gonna give you my ATM cards we both
have something of value from the other
person all right
and your code is it is one two three
four and yours sir one two three five
thank you
okay that that is a Ralph's Rewards Card
okay that is a credit card placeholder
you would find in a translucent sleeve
and a brand new wallet
right quick
okay Carter
I can stay here all night
so why don't you and I cut the crap and
you tell me what happened on March 15th
and what's in it for Carter Finley
what's in it for you is I don't send you
back to jail
the guy's name is cat branchman I met
him downtown at a club called the clutch
and kitten you may have heard of it it's
down on the corner of hang and Fur
Street cat branchman
so what's a guy like you and a guy named
cat
okay I know what you're doing Finley
you're just using what you see in my
poster I'm not detective I'm telling the
truth we'll see how much truth you tell
after a few weeks in solitary control
fine detective you've twisted my arm
that's better
the guy's name wasn't cat branchman
it was a Chinese guy named Mr meow
he's the real gang boss
story went he hung guys from trees and
took pictures of them Finley used to run
a club downtown a front of course called
it the Paul and poster Finley ran it
with a guy named Hong in Dar okay
try this one more time
[Music]
Finley
who do you work for
coffee Mr Coffee
coop
coffee Coop his name was baldy tall man
coffee Coop now you're just talking
about me Finley I'm gonna give you one
more chance
who is in charge his name was angry man
the warehouse is located in the diploma
for being a detective I want a name
Justin thank you
don't say hang God damn it do not say
hang
nope hangman Justin cap Finley
's poster do not say poster or
cat cat poster okay that's it I'm losing
my patience Winslow get this [__] out
of here
thank you
[Music]
I'm losing my patience
let's try this one more time
getting too old for it
[Music]
well played Detective
well played indeed
hey Carter
you hang in there
telling you it's totally legal these
doctors don't prescribe medical
marijuana to anyone man what do I tell
them I need it for it doesn't matter
they want to give you prescription
that's how they get paid just make
something up
hey Mr Washington welcome Hey doctor or
I'm going to ask a couple questions
what
age
AIDS as in uh as in I got it need lots
of weed to get rid of it
okay okay AIDS
um wow all right uh are you are you sure
you're not suffering from anything else
like you know back pain nope anxiety
cool as a cucumber how about insomnia
sleep like a baby
with AIDS okay Mr Washington let's just
slow your roll for a second here if you
had AIDS then I would have to verify it
by saying test results whereas if you
have back pain or anxiety or anything
else that I can't test for then I can
give you this prescription for cannabis
right now oh understand oh yeah I see I
guess my bad okay so leprosy no no
because if you had leprosy I'd have to
quarantine you ouch what do you no okay
I see your fingers falling off don't do
that though that's not gonna work scurvy
nope Ricketts what no consumption no Mr
Washington something from this Century
schizophrenia no you don't have
schizophrenia just do keep it simple
please
what the hell is that I don't know what
that is a fish hook in my leg just pick
something off this list I can't reach it
why not paralyzed
does your face hurt Mr Washington yeah
then this should help
come on yes I'm here
I promise you'll never forget about me
you'll take care of our little girl
love her
yes
[Music]
promise me you'll stay strong for her
yes yes
I promise
and promise me you'll never sleep with
another woman
I hear you
promise me you'll take care of Mr big
fluffy tail yes
the most loved cat in the world
and that you won't look at porn
oh
no pornography muscle Brown says what
is that a yes
yo better believe our heart washing his
hand girl
you love me right yes I love you yes and
we're soul mates right yes
so you will never ever ever think of
someone else while masturbating right
message received I don't understand is
that a yes
is that a promise your request has been
filed say you promise
forget about
huh
I need to hear you say it I say I Pro I
promise you promise you
you promise
say it
okay I promise no air quotes
I promise I promise
what are you promising I promise what
you said oh fine forget it yes I mean
he's promised to go see my mom every day
so zero pornography done
I like that
nurse
fix my wife
[Laughter]
don't touch me right now
it's not all about you
foreign
things first I do not care that you're a
multi-platinum selling rapper gun rack
what I care about is that I 100 percent
know that you murdered Darnell Simmons
so you better start talking
yeah but you ain't got now
okay
you know I'm actually I'm very glad that
you said that
because I respectfully
I beg to differ
[Music]
and by the way it was November 9th
I mean
I got a vivid imagination
I couldn't have shot done now
I would have my cousin's birthday party
Red Lobster November 9th
at Red Lobster geez I gotta tell you gun
right I find that really hard to believe
a mobster it's a lot anyone could tell
this if you know about my allergy to all
selfish
just confess conrack
fast that shellfish is the only thing
that rhymes with tell this
Estus bars
nouns adjectives
they just happen to be in adult order
but
we ain't got no hurl
shut up sorry now with a long-ass gun
and tossed it into the aquarium
I have no idea what that object is
if I had to identify it I would call it
a gun
of the long ass variety some seaweed in
there too look the tattoo I had to bring
it to you I ain't killing on it
so much in real slow when I'm lying and
I was laughing super hard and gone that
was dying the name of the album is I
killed Darnell Simmons
that's a picture of you a picture of you
and besides
behind you you're going away for a long
time you understand you're gonna confess
if it's the last thing you'll ever do
when you hear me get back
I'll be the audience
oh he's free to go what no no no no we
have everything we need no I was Simon's
girlfriend she just confessed to the
whole thing infidelity crime and passion
let's go Mr rack
[Music]
bonus track I got a ride or die [__] I
think you get the gist and when you let
me out I'm gonna blow a little kiss this
is my confession admissible in court I
killed Darnell Simmons for sport
that's right I'm a murderer come get me
come down the hall you can't get me okay
okay okay you got me dummy
[Music]